[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
the best player in the league you like
lebron and you like patrick
i like you you're ready you only like
yeah what is it you only like the
the popular guy no i like the best guy
the most popular though too
so lebron patrick who i mean steph curry
is more popular than lebron
no you don't think so maybe maybe
no not i wouldn't say more liked whoa
steph curry is not i'd say lebron's more
more like well just you just share like
you go by sure population like the world
a lot of people
hate lebron i know but that means you
have more like if you have haters you're
gonna have more people that like you i
get you
but don't you think so worldwide you
don't think like little kids look up to
steph curry more because they're like i
can be next to steph curry than lebron i
just don't think
steph curry's as famous as lebron like
when's the last that's true
when's the last time you saw a young kid
wearing steph curry's outsiders
which is another issue that is true i
like your shoes
great yeah his shoes are kind of good
you're but you're just you're just not
in the race
it's like signing with you know like a
huge label
he could have shot with nike but he took
the money he took the money
he has ownership too exactly so you want
to it's a money play but as far as like
legacy play like if you're not with nike
yeah like you tell me if you should like
first day of school eighth grade show up
in steph curry's people like
that's cool you show up in some [ __ ]
fresh
bronze or kdz jordan's like
it's just different wait what did then
uh i mean maybe he's trying to change
the narrative so he's like man
everyone's doing that
everyone's signing with puma though
that's the new wave now
so guys are
[Laughter]
[Applause]
those are dope yeah no puma's bacon hot
[ __ ] nipsey had a puma
yeah they have some dope-ass collabs i
like a lot of pumas but i've never been
like
jonesing for a puma i've never been
pissed when i didn't get puma okay
i mean yeah but not easy but we know
nike is the grand master that's the
godfather of everything
you have to do is right underneath yeezy
made uh adidas yeezy's the most i
thought it was straight
no no no no you're gonna do anything to
do this no no he's not he's a nike guy
and jordan i'm tripping yeah
yeah but uh yeah yeah the most expensive
shoe now
easy yeah yep it came out report this
morning oh
with nike his his uh his prototype black
black is the most expensive yeah yeah
okay oh cause he was those are probably
i think how much did they go for and
what's up bring those up chin
up uh yeah it'll be it'll be in trending
news
just typing yeah they're so sick yeah i
don't
well i don't know why uh nike just
doesn't re-release them look at that
right there god damn one million dollars
no bro most expensive shoe yeah
would you cop uh b uh it's straight
investment so i'm sure to go up damn bro
i mean them they're hard but they're not
like no they're not like
okay okay that's what i'm saying no nike
definitely has shoes that look like that
i don't know why nike just doesn't do
like uh you know how they do like the
retro jordan ones do a retro virtual
easy which i heard they were gonna do
but they can't use like the usb logo
good stuff but they can use the design
he doesn't own
the design yeah but yeah that's true but
it's more
i think it's more exclusive when you
have that yeezy name morning for sure
gee would you rock those
i mean like he's like be said all right
how come i would
wear those every day you what you would
oh yeah every day i could not i was am i
saying
i'm looking for [ __ ] i'm looking at you
wait are you serious every day
bro they're not i mean they're popular
oh yeah i'd be the only one
i like it nobody has that that's what
i'm saying how about their mass
produce i wouldn't be rocking them but
those you got the prototype yeezys
one of them dollars one you would you
i would get a tattoo of them wait yeah i
would get a yeezy
man
are the all red ones these ones look
like they have like a
glow in the dark bottom there's some
like
pink on them and they're yeezys those
are the best looking yeezys by far over
the uh red octobers
yeah yeah i got it it's red october here
all right
it's a lot man you can't wear them with
every outfit and that's so expensive
look at those big don't get me wrong i
love you
i don't know go back
no go back chin there's no way i'll go
back one more
yeah one more and then uh scoot over
oh you heat up oh don't type in red
october just type in uh nike yeezys
your brother wants those uh [ __ ] foam
i know i don't understand
no no that's not the color but i get oh
the black ones are hard to beat yeah the
black ones are dope
it's a great one justin has the black
right
yeah it doesn't have the white no you
went to the right october right picking
red shoes for the love of god
what do you want go to the gray ones the
gray and green ones this one
no no no no the green yeah there you go
chin just
glued on those red shoes he's like
they're just so bright
i don't know i don't know i appreciate
you
he's like a cat with a red dot
i like that skin tone yeah those are
filthy
bring him back nike yes wait oh they
they don't have those any or
no [ __ ] no you can't get those and how
much are those
listen how do you how do you get six
seven grand how do you get
i don't know nothing what you gotta have
i don't [ __ ] get
shoes that expensive like like you just
because it's
kanye kanye well they're like they're so
exclusive they didn't make many of them
they and they're disconnected and so
that's what makes it
it's like expensive yeah because they're
because there's like it's like you're
only making the limited amount of the
loser it's like the nike app you know
they'll say they go for 125 the reason
they sell it so fast because all these
i guess these people want to make money
they're not real sneaker heads but
they're just flipping the shoes
so if they go for like a special collab
with a dunk or something they're only
making i don't know
500 pairs so if they retail at 125
they're just trying to get them because
they're gonna flip them for six seven
hundred
got it so only 500 pairs
but then also there's fakes yeah they're
going up to four thousand
four yeah there's fakes but there's
fakes of these yeezys of course
real sneaker heads you can tell all day
you can tell
even watches now guys are going around
like uh certain guys that post a watch
you know and then these real watch guys
who know watches will do a whole video
on how they're feeling another dude
no they're doing that too with punches
oh yeah damn chains
for real diamond tester uh yeah yeah i
knew i knew
yeah i remember that but i know they
were doing it like with the watches too
bro
everything
[Laughter]
what pretty expensive still 300 probably
yeah four i don't know
like bro i got these new uh yeezys and
then yeah
they're probably coming out the strength
easy to spell why i
z i said i got the reasons
i mean i've seen fake shoes yeah and
they look pretty damn spot-on
there's just so much detail huh yeah
well [ __ ] you know yeah people have like
lights and [ __ ] yeah it's where they
could play yeah there's certain things
to tell
and then cause i watch those videos on
youtube and then some of them most will
almost be identical to
you know come from the same factory the
same people who make them identical but
then when you get the box
the numbers don't add up they can you
wait what do you mean
so like if i get a shoe from like stockx
or from a plug or
like i got those prototype ones i'll
take a picture of the box you know the
the code and the size where it says the
size and the name i'll take pick that
sent to my guys at suplex
and they're like not fam like those
aren't
the numbers don't match the vid and the
cereal don't match okay
those are fake shout outs that's how
they figure it out that's [ __ ] insane
it's insane but like dude i mean i'm
looking i have the real one here i have
to pay when he's like i know
he's like he's like you can rock them if
you want to wear them out or do whatever
but
there's another thing as far as you if
you're trying to flip them you can't
flip them okay so that's that's just
which i don't i'm not yeah
i don't think you're out there okay i
got these shoes no i don't flip shoes
that'd be funny if
brendan was flipping shoes i'd be down
to two i would be down to trade shoes if
someone had some dope kicks and one of
my dips
i'd be down for trade yeah but i'm not
trying to make money off yeah
hey come on can you do something for me
dawg what can you wipe your eye oh do i
get sleep in mine
yeah yeah i was like a deep sleep it's a
deep sleep
it's been bugging me i'm like looking at
you like this dog
why would you say something i was out
there like why would you wait to around
here
i didn't even you're an [ __ ] i know i
mean hey yo y'all tell me [ __ ]
what you talking about right you're
right you told me everything about me
you're growing out the hair it's
starting to go yeah yeah little by
little yeah you're growing it back out
yeah yeah
you got that good hair i don't think
it's good hair oh it's not
no you look like you got good hair when
it's when it's like long long
how long do you do how long are you
gonna do it like how long you go like
before you go down here the only reason
i really cut it because i messed up
yeah i think we should let it go
huh what happened here yeah i gotta hit
fight
fight bar fight not bar fight street
race
street race that's the most asian thing
i've ever heard
i got [ __ ] up i found a vietnamese
gang her people
oh this is my uncle sorry this is where
you got jumped i got jumped yeah
but what did he hit you with a bottle
you know those mag lights oh those
huge bag lights i think the
arrested yeah you've never been around a
cop i mean the newer ones
oh that thing sleeker you got hit with
that yeah but
yeah it was super long it was like a
baton
oh my god so that should that does that
knock you out
no that's that's what's crazy i was in a
dream i was like
instantly oh yeah so basically
dude so basically you took it on the
chin no took it on the head though
that was a nice round okay
it felt like a water hose of like warm
water hose it was like
constantly bleeding yeah and everything
everything's slow motion what'd you say
after
you're like [ __ ] i ate that [ __ ] my
friends just went at them
do you like oh you're first of all bro
no did you
did you win the race the car race is
that why they're upset or no he was
sitting on my car so i started
oh wow oh yeah you can't let no
[ __ ] sit on you
disrespect i know can you imagine
someone just randomly just laying on
your car
no uh we're [ __ ] malick
i was gonna buy it i was getting i had a
mclaren dealer drive up the mclaren here
i was going to buy it
i come out oh my god sit on the hood
like some instagram
thought the dealer was like oh my god
what are you doing man
i was like oh my god the worst thing
ever oh i still have the photos
yeah i was like i am so sorry man
can i explain myself go for it you can't
be around nice stuff man no i could get
i could be around nice he was all
denimed up too i was didn't know
listen i act different when i have jeans
on
yeah his car got told last week why what
happened wrong no i went parker
live on your sentry got towed bro took
the center why
bro because they was hating yeah but why
did they
tell us i love how brenda's just
staying with you on this and trying to
okay but why did they take it
that's it freaking out that's so you
what you don't see is me going what the
[ __ ] in the back
that's him we're gonna take your hand
down
to the right where's oh yeah that is
pretty fist balled up like the order of
me
play you the live video because it's uh
a photo but it's a live photo so then it
plays video too
you do that on here yeah right now oh
you did
yeah oh that's a computer doug hey
okay really okay
[Music]
the deal is like now please i don't even
know cars like that and i would never
sit on that car
yeah all right kids let's take a little
break from the shenanigans with the boys
because guess what now more than ever
it's critical to take care of yourself
and avoid unnecessary trips to the
doctor
the chiropractor the masseuse you don't
want to do that man social distance have
an effect on everything these days
and nothing is more important right now
than keeping your body healthy
and most important pain free so if
you're sitting at home suffering from
aches and pains from arthritis
backaches muscle soreness from your
workout joint pain whatever it is
you want to try a drug-free solution
then you owe it to yourself to try the
product
that you're probably hearing about
across so many podcasts these days
talking about cryo-free cbd pain relief
roll-on
it's an all-natural topical pain
reliever that instantly ices out the
pain with a one-two punch of super cold
methanol
and hemp cbd simply roll cryofreeze onto
your back neck
hands wrist wherever you want and it
helps block the pain reduce inflammation
improve muscle and joint flexibility
cryofreeze contains 10 powerful
ingredients
that combine to provide a powerhouse
dose of relief which can last up to
eight
hours much longer than any other product
like this all right
omax is offering you guys 20 off a one
month supply of omax cryofreeze the roll
on cbd i just told you about this
discount also applies
towards any product on the site all
right just go to h
or just go to omax health.com today
enter the code fighter that's omax
health.com
enter the code fighter to get 20 off
omax cryofreeze
and it is statewide cryofreeze was
inspired by cryotherapy which you see
everybody doing these days which means
cold therapy a treatment exposes the
body to cold temperatures in order to
numb and reduce pain
or inflammation professional nfl nba
ufc athletes such as steph curry lebron
james use therapy on a regular basis
if you have pain that won't go away you
gotta try it man
omax cryo-free simply roll it over where
it hurts and ice out the pain no i see
creams horrible fragrances like some of
those
other products crowd freeze works within
five minutes of applying all right
so go to omaxhealth.com enter the code
fighter to get 20 off
cryofreeze and statewide that's omax
health.com enter the code fighter
to get 20 off statewide there's nobody
on the planet like you so why would you
buy a generic mattress built for
everybody else man
you got to get with these helix
mattresses i have them in my crib i
can't get rid of my in-laws i can't get
rid of my friends everybody wants to
stay the night
all you got to do if you want a bed like
this helix sleep has a short little quiz
takes two minutes to complete
then they match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress just
for your thick ass
with your side sleeper hot sleeper plush
firm with helix there's no more
confusion no more compromising on
average mattress
we got you covered man just go to
helixsleep.com
fighter take the two minute sleep quiz
and they will match you with
the mattress built for your body all
right they have a 10 year warranty
you try it out for 100 nights risk free
they even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will
helix offer you guys up to 200 off all
mattress orders and free pillows
for the fire the kids listeners at helix
sleep.com
fighter that's helix sleep
h-e-l-i-x-sleep.com
fighter for up to two hundred dollars
off
so why did your car get um bro there was
so i'm at a mic
killing it and um they had saw a park
it was a driveway right industrial
street they had plenty of cars parked
so i was about to do a quick set so my
my back was sticking out a little bit in
the driveway just a little bit like
a little bit like where cars turn in but
no no it was close this
this spot it's like 10 o'clock at night
okay it's industrial like they had
construction work all that
it's closed so i'm like i need a park so
my i parked a little bit i knew i wasn't
gonna fit
my ass is sticking out a little bit okay
i'm on stage there's a hey bro whoever
got a nissan
altima they tore your [ __ ] i was like oh
y'all better get that [ __ ] cause i got a
sentra
and it was like what club was that then
bro oh no this is that uh this
open mic okay in the backyard right now
on the street on orange street like up
the street where my my girl lives so i'm
right around the corner so i drive
so i'm like all right i'm like oh
somebody has a sentra i mean i have a
center it was like oh bro i think
is it black i was like yeah it's like i
think it's yours so i run outside
i tell do i'm like bro what you doing
it's already on the left already on the
left
but here's the thing though i'm like bro
what are you doing he was like yeah it's
poking out and people can't get back i'm
like bro what are you talking about i'm
here let me just
move my car yeah he was like bro i
already gave you a ticket i was like let
me pay the ticket don't take my car and
now here's the crazy thing so we're
cheating wait they give you a ticket
into it yeah but here's
where chin is is where la toe is right
here so we're so we're right here this
is where the mic is
chin that's where la toe is so he
literally just drive a couple of
feet up to put my car in the garage i'm
like bro i'm right behind you just let
me get my car
he was like nah bro it's the city if you
should you could just probably give him
cash
i mean he would have dropped it down
what did i say earlier he said he said
bro
he's like dude i'll give you i give you
cash what's he gonna take to drop the
car down
because he wants cash yeah i didn't take
that i gave it to you but i was so
pissed off like bro
i haven't i didn't know that was my
first time now i'm pissed off no
i'm gonna go tonight now you gotta drive
up to where the the junkyard i already
went there i'm arguing with the guy i'm
like bro
why did y'all take my car yeah they say
well you illegally parked
yeah that's why i was like bro it's a
good argument yeah it's not good
but you did i know i wish your car
didn't get towed but to their defense
you
did park illegally okay okay you know
okay okay
but you could have gave him cash and got
it down okay but it's an escalade right
there in front of me parked on some
goddamn cones
nice it's it's construction work they're
parked on and it's a bench
right next to my bummer so so you didn't
get the car out of the no it's still
impounded
i also like how much weight say to get
it out they was like bro
let me just take this is it a daily
drink it was 25
i had 25 ticket
he said bro overnight it's gonna cost
333 dollars no
i'm gonna leave it overnight if i leave
it overnight i'll say bro let me just
get my car
i was like i leave tomorrow i go out of
town it was like yeah well you have to
get it when you get it
get back i'm like 325 dollars a day
330 i thought i thought it was cheaper
than you no it's not bro
the city is starving for money yes so
that was like bro it's up to the city
now i'm like what
close to four 25 so then why couldn't
you get it out
last night exactly that's what i'm
trying to say why not but
brendan your guess is better than mine
because i actually said give me my car
back listen
wait wait wait wait wait wait he's
saying i'll pay whatever 25 give me the
car
i was like bro they said no they were
like no you got to have your information
out to the city
you got to pay the ticket bro give me
the give me the ticket
so you have to pay the ticket first yes
could you just pay it online
like right there like they say the
office the office hours is 9 a.m to 5
p.m
i'll show you the tickets so i'm like
i'm like bro leave tomorrow just give me
my
for 25 tickets give me the ticket
damn so i'm gonna go to joe brown
tomorrow judge joe brown
yep so you left your car like that was
my best friend
that was my best joe joe brown
the tow truck driver was what ethnicity
just guess
black no he's white he was white
officer montgomery i got his badge
number i forgot it but he
but he was just a tow truck he was in a
cop was he no i s the guy he said
well i call him oh the guy that follows
you know no the guy knows to the guy who
i was like bro
because the tow guy doesn't give the
ticket no oh it's the the parking people
the person i was i was doing behind the
parking meter the
the guy who i was talking to behind the
screen because i was yelling at him when
i got that
never good but bro because they're not
gonna work with you bro
you took my car and i'm looking at it he
didn't even drive it up so i'm like bro
you ain't processing any papers
just listen i pay the ticket i don't
even give you money i'm not i'm begging
i'm like rocky money come on bro he was
like this big money he was like bro
it's up to the city now it's not our
hands my hands are tied yeah i'm like
[ __ ]
what so yeah so he could he could have
paid homie right there yeah
i didn't know i was thinking that that
would have been my that would have been
my first thought because he didn't
because it's gonna cost you how much you
think now
well well you're gone for wednesday
thursday friday
saturday and back late sunday and it's
300
a day yeah so that's it's gonna be
around 1200 bucks
yeah i bet you could have got that car
off there that night for 300 bucks cash
well he didn't i gave it to him if he
said that but he didn't tell me that
you can't it's a legal firmness yeah he
can't you just gotta do i'll get 300
cash now bring it down i'll go there
right here we'll call it even i think he
was a dick though but let me tell you
why
because my car he doesn't get money like
he doesn't get money he doesn't make
that much he doesn't money from that but
the tow truck is right here and my car
is where chin
is you can't let me bro my it was
sticking out a little bit
you have a biz you have an estrogen why
would you touch you arguing the same
thing
as your solution you could have just you
could have probably got it down
i get what you're saying but rules
aren't rules mallet
it happens you know it's the worst
25 ticket i don't know 1200 no
said he's gonna get you man wait so oh
gosh yeah yeah
i'm basically i'm starting i don't know
i was saying you're not just trying to
find another solution there's no
solution
well now now it's once it's in there
there's no yeah
you understand my frustration last night
you think we should just kind of
forget about the sentra just leave it in
there elise can you do that
leave sheila she yeah yeah cause what
they do he's just leaving i don't know
they do those auctions yeah
that's what they do
because if you leave it in there
is that
that's why you're not too upset right
now he was like well it's decision
2012 let's say it to cost 1500 bucks to
get it out which it will with
processing fees yeah so 1200 wait
plus prices yeah but you told me 325. i
cut it at 300. it was 333.
yeah i see so that's gonna add up so you
so you're talking
yeah dude you're talking spring it's
gonna be about 1500 with taxes plus a 25
ticket hey about fifteen hundred dollars
how much is that
it's gonna be 13 40 before fees yeah
there it is four feet
four did you did you do the thirty
percent tax no i didn't that's why i'm
going to add that
thirty percent taxes california can't
get out here being the accountant right
now
is gonna be 1742 1
742 to get the central out
how much do you love sheila how much did
they pay at the open mic
that's not that that was a free one huh
if we walk okay
we're gonna get yeah we're going to cut
sheila loose i just wonder if they if
they're just like
you let's say you leave it in there for
30 nights like dude yours 325
times three now times 30. no like are
they just gonna like keep adding up like
you know
after a certain point i think they
auction it off can i sue
no you made the mistake you have no
ground to stand on
i know you're frustrated the rules are
rules dude it won't hold up in court
i'm with you it's a dick move but i know
rules yeah
it's [ __ ] oh come on
and maybe this is a blessing in disguise
what do you mean maybe
i don't know thank you yeah maybe you
know you're trying to be no you're
trying to
find a oh you know we could be like in
that movie a gun in 60 seconds
i'm nicholas cage and you're the hot
chick and we go steal
why the hell am i the feminine person in
this car no you're the hottest one in
here the hottest one in here
and then we got to figure out how to get
this car out of the junkyard okay have
you ever seen god in 60 seconds
i've seen it i can't remember they get
they get a car from the junkyard
okay i know exactly where is it where it
is it's right there we can get it
wait so all they're doing is trying to
get a car from a junkyard yeah that's
the whole movie
no they they got to get a hundred cars
oh angelina jolie four days
is that her right yeah she's looking
kind of busted there but it was just for
the roll
and that's the car damn that's the car
they were trying to get i know that that
was the
sheila look way better than that yeah
that um
i forget what car they're trying to get
but they have to get a list and ship it
in a certain amount of time oh and this
car just happened to be in this junkyard
one of the like hundred cars they had to
get but it wasn't that one oh so they
had to get a collective of course
the gt 500 was the car oh in the
junkyard
no that that was the that was like the
unicorn that he always had
issues with eleanor eleanor is his car
right eleanor was his car
that was his baby i forgot which car
they were going to after that movie that
car
[ __ ] skyrocketed like everyone wanted
and you saw a bunch of dupe kits and
replicas of that like that car was so
[ __ ] frosty
damn that car's sick so basically malik
well this
is y'all moving yeah bringing out about
to remake this i just don't know if we
do
go through all this to steal a um
2001 central it's not 2001. now if you
had like a ferrari so i'm like all right
we better figure this out but i think
we're just gonna have to
we know the loss i still got i still got
a couple of miles on that it's 142 000
miles
uh 2012. those bills run those runs run
great good on gas
good on gas i don't know i just had i
don't know what the movie
yeah bro you said it she got all the
tires i got a new tire on there oh the
steering
the steering doesn't work right yeah it
don't work but we can get that fixed
you got we got the speaker box we got a
little speaker yeah whenever i cruise
we're going to use a little
bluetooth thing yeah i don't know what
the move is for you man
we're getting that car back yeah you're
getting that car back i don't know
i don't know all right
nicholas
yeah he didn't do his actual stealing in
that oh he's just
not again i'm nick this cage i'm just
keeping the ideas here okay so chappelle
and you gotta pull i forget who uh he
was doing it with
the young kid who did it with him i
think it was his brother or some [ __ ]
yeah that's why he's stealing the cars
because his brother got in trouble um
got him with like the russian mafia or
some [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where you watching
oh yeah giovanni ripley
yeah he's a nice guy
and will patton helps out vinnie jones
is in it
scott kane's in it yeah delore uh
linda like a pena's in it great
great movie man
what do you say he's picking some random
guys
who's he talking about don't worry about
it bro we got to get sheila back
bro real talk because again 17 i mean
1700 dollars that's a lot bro
no and i wasn't even in the room they
had the biz right there
he parked in on side of a cone and then
they had the effort i know you can
[ __ ] story
yeah you've said it four times now and
we're i need y'all to be
at this point if you say it one more
time i'm gonna be on the city side
you're sick of it i'm sick brenda's out
there with signs don't
i just had a small check it passed yeah
i don't know what that's tough dude
it's all good it happens dog man black
black black chin all right doesn't
matter
color color faded by the sun
like like how much is that going virgin
yeah what's this go for like let's just
see if we should just buy a new one
i'm not even trying to be funny bro what
the [ __ ] is that real man
no you're not bro ooh i saw one said 17
that yeah
that's exactly 1784. that's exactly how
much you want
kelly blue but go to kelly blue book
they'll tell you how about your car
you can put it miles in here and
everything all right here we go expert
review but it got to be a black one hold
up ad block
oh it's okay actually you know i sold my
99 wrangler for more than what it was
worth on
kelly blue book how much you sell it but
that was because that was because it's
frankly
wrangler yeah wranglers have a good
resale value yeah [ __ ] yeah
nissan is uh up there right no okay
uh-uh unless
yeah there's a new one that came out too
well you have to sign up to figure it
out they're sick
yeah oh that's whack oh dang all right
well just knows around that it's
most likely 2 000 000.
i think we get what we need to figure
out before we make a choice about it is
are they going to charge you like are
they like dude yeah we sold your [ __ ]
car after 60 days but you still owe us
money for keeping it
here oh that's right and then and then
you're gonna
have a warrant a lean out for your a
lean out also because
i don't know how it works listen you're
not going to get that far
you got this yeah but you would think
that if you just were like right [ __ ]
you keep it like all right cool man
oh there it goes my car got told what
happens if i don't pick it up click on
that
chin read it my worthless car got
impounded
car was killed by the cops or expired
tags uh and i'm pretty well decided on
letting them keep the damn thing if i do
so
i don't know
will i owe them any significant amount
of money i've received letters stating
that i'd be charged remain under the
storage cost that's what i'm worried
about
all right odds are you'll be fine for
storage costs which depend on how much
it may be worth
the tow yards take uh yards time to take
you to small claims court and sue you
for the storage fees
possibly their legal retainer costs my
question to you is why not sell it take
pictures throw it on craigslist for the
price of the storage fees
plus a couple of dollars for yourself
and meet the buy at the tow yard
that's what i did on the vehicle totaled
out was taking the pound that's not bad
i could sell my car yeah i'd be like yo
it's in the pound but here it is
yeah and 142 miles it's gonna be a tough
sell
because you're because you're gonna have
to sell for at least double to make
money
what do you mean so you're so you're
gonna so you're gonna they're gonna need
to cover the cost for storing the things
which is gonna be
17 at least let's say two grand that
everything included
two grand the car's only worth two grand
so you're gonna need
four grand and is the car um do you oh
no
no no it's paid off pay it off
so come on man that's sheila that's what
she gives you so just get
yeah two grand to get ready and i and
this and i just got the car wash
yeah it's gonna be in the sun for days
dude
there's gonna be bumps pissing on him
sleeping in that junkyard the other
thing is we're going to try and steal it
back you ever heard of a junkyard dog
oh they got those wallers yeah they got
rottweilers worth it man
have you had like a mclaren or some [ __ ]
then we're gonna risk these junkyard
dogs but for us
what memories i'm getting in fist cups
with some [ __ ]
large sandlot dogs i don't want those
problems man
probably get it operation central yeah
again
operation yeah i'm george clooney if
this is ocean's 11.
i'm just spitting balling ideas here you
guys got to execute the plan i'm brad
pitt
nope brad pitt don't do the stealing
you're the small chinese guy in the box
oh
the guy that sit there i'm bernie mac
why are you burning
hmm yo you're gonna be the distraction
you're gonna go up the thing and just
cause a spirit
yeah yeah look i can do backflips hey
look at me
or you just going like hey do you have a
center and go get your hand out of my
pocket he's like what yeah
you're just going to be like what'd you
call me yeah yeah okay and then
then cat's filming it but here's the
thing cat's pretty small
we open up the fence cap and christian
both small
under yeah and i give cats disguised as
dogs
this guy's you guys dress up as dogs
and they start you got to start flirting
with them dogs and they must start
mating they're brilliant and they
breathe
malik i'm sorry to tell you i think
sheila belongs to the streets
i think sheila belongs to the streets
all right all right do here put my
george clooney hat on here
no we go to the junkyard what we do is
we have
chin we have chin hack into the guy's
computer
of cats popping up he's like who's this
little [ __ ] what the feet asian
tamale
and then and then where she's like only
fans holy [ __ ] and then
cat rolls up there he's like oh my god
he's looking at it flirting yeah looks
at the computer
nissan sentra wait we can't say that
because
you or you start really flirting with
them and what you're going to do is
we're going to honeydick them honey and
you're going gonna be like hey
what's gonna take to get that sentra and
then he's gonna give you some dirty
description
you're like yeah i'm down for that let's
get the car out first though yeah
and then you do whatever you want to do
from there when do i come in
you'll jump in the car
now we're talking big debt then we gotta
break you out of prison and i we don't
want those problems oh hold on hold on
chappelle my only fans money will get
you out of prison
i like that okay so l.a told me to tell
her do whatever she wants so he went
there they gotta buzz you in
right so they have like a gate so he
went in through the gate that
he had the garage to so i'm trying to
it's a garage it's not a
it's not a uh chain-link fence no it's a
garage
and then they have bars that's right
they have bars yeah this is in l.a
yeah and i have no because i don't get
my stuff out the car nope i don't know
what
mm-hmm so we have a chain line i planted
a bar my plan was for a junkyard fence
no this is not a garage no this is
that's a different animal
wait no they'll give up yeah now
out what just right like that i'm out
george clooney would have found that i
was just about to say this is a bigger
stake in the higher operation where's
matt damon
he's in that movie too yeah all right
another idea george clooney here another
idea
we upload you doing some freaky [ __ ] on
cats only fans
cat's subscription goes up cat gives you
that money you get your car out of the
toe
because we'll probably make two grand if
you get that big black dick out
i'll bring it down i'll bring it hey
look there it is okay so look ooh
i can do that thank you that's not a
garage no no no no
wait is this one on is there a dog on
site no that's not it uh chin
that's the one is this a 90s thing where
they have dogs patrolling the junkyards
yeah i don't know why you keep saying
i'm telling you they have dogs man
because we're not the first dummies oh
he lives in there he had a junk yard
look at this
dog he's crushing it man it's called l.a
for sure
yeah thank you uh santa monica boulevard
on the corner
[Laughter]
wake up whatever car you want to take
that right
yeah he's got his own little trailer
he's got snakes in there he's got a
snake snake stick he's got snake
snake your friend's so lonely
[Laughter]
you sure that's the name bro it's it's
on santa monica boulevard yes lato
well this is all that popped up on yelp
the is there the oh there it is later
that's what i picked earlier
you sure and he's now santa monica
boulevard i'm sure someone's listening
could probably
help you out oh yeah please probably
works there that listens huh thank you
yeah i don't know about you it's always
called employee
yeah it's on orange drive and santa
monica boulevard
uh please help me out or if you have
ideas
it's on the corner and it's like it's
like it's a garage they take the uh
cars up up to the garage so we're on the
first floor as soon as you walk in you
gotta get buzzed in
and it's numb but like gate bars and i'm
talking to the guy behind sure
yeah now they got three guys in the back
oh there's three yes
two on the computer one is that this is
a nightmare so we got a lot of this this
is this is [ __ ] out
of junk yards this is alcatraz before
there's three guards yes three cars we
thought there was just one
yeah deal with three dudes yeah
and i don't know what it's like we
didn't look into we'll have chin hacking
the system
hopefully we want them like men's like
and then we're not like yeah
yeah because then we don't use cat as
bait and then we use chapel you look at
handsome now
we use the three of us or if they if
they're into little twinks christians
how bad do you want it you moved out to
l.a oh
man give my car baby listen to get
sheila i'm thinking that i like that
they're like white christian queer like
yeah dude i [ __ ]
don't work for friendship they asked me
to suck this guy's dick to get
some weird sandwiches yeah it's like the
guy from firefest who was gonna suck
dick for water yeah i need that level of
dedication
by you guys yes come on man that guy was
like
dude dude that guy that's a guy that's
the level of commitment i want out of
you guys dude
you watched that doc right well i saw
that clip you saw that clip
he's so goddamned down i hate it it's
crazy how everyone was fooled by that
it's so insane i was gonna go to it i
feel like you could do i feel like you
could do it now
like people are looking for [ __ ] to do
yeah i mean i see
i mean yeah he got it i mean you're
gonna have some real legal problems
oh he did oh yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying
i think he went to i think he went to
prison oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah you're
going prison i think yeah no he's out
though yeah
well it was like two years it was a
two-year i think he only had to do that
about your car i'm all out of ideas
thank you bro this sounds like a fighter
in the kid's gut
3d sketch it's not a sketch it's real
life
one hurt we all hurt i don't understand
why i am not hurt by this car i think
we need to just chalk it up as a lost
dude bro
that the best idea was that was that
reddit or google so we should be looking
for cars for you
yeah but why why i hear you but i'm not
dude we put two thousand down on a new
lease though oh yeah
we got low payments you could do that i
i will i hear what you're saying but
that car has
now waiting for like jay's trying to
trick you into getting
but we could get you something dope what
is jay trying to trick him again m4
and bmw relax yeah don't listen to the
yeah i'm saying you those are [ __ ]
sick but you got good credit yeah so
david
dude let's get you a used [ __ ]
godzilla nissan
and be like bye sheila damn that front
end is
so if i leave my card there then i'm
gonna be like what you have to take care
of those uh no
yeah see that's what you want to do the
storage price yeah you have to take care
of that
they're gonna come after you see i'm
saying so why either way we gotta get
sheila back
y'all y'all are misunderstood you said i
had good credit
if i don't get there if i don't get her
back and that's gonna take your credit
yes oh that'll affect your credit yeah
for sure
bro we gotta get sheila back so i
understand why we go coming up with
plans and operations we need to be
thinking about
it's in the junkyard right now 17
another idea okay come on
thank you cool it's a good one i can
tell this is the solid
george clooney idea okay this is a
george clinton all right
we set that thing on fire why would we
kill sheila
because then it's their problem you're
like dude what and then you owe me money
that car was worth 5 000.
okay like that happened on your terms on
your lot now here's the prom
okay we have quite the fan base and now
the plan is out
[Music]
what a problem to have though i think
one of the things are you stressed out
about it hell yeah
yeah you don't have a car i have a car
and we leave like right after this
but you your girl's got two cards yeah
yeah you used one oh she was so loyal
she was so down
uh she what she can't pick me up from uh
the lato like it was late i'm arguing
with him
and she she was like you show you i was
like knocking him and she went in and
she was like sir
i don't have time for this right i'm
busy what does he need to do
he was like yo she he needs to call the
city yeah you tell him and he pay and
she's like okay that's all he needs to
do and she's like yeah and she's like
get your [ __ ] let's go
i'm gonna idea here george clooney again
you're six figure queen yeah she's in
town correct yeah
you're headed to naples with me to do
shows yeah why doesn't your six figure
you pay it online your six figure queen
gets it out so you don't owe
hundred dollars she gets yeah don't you
have a homie or your girl get it out
your girl also has money she has money
so go get my [ __ ] car lady
you're right all right that's that's the
best plan you have right now i mean i
thought blowing up was the best plan
yeah i'm gonna text after this show yeah
but no they said i need my my license
and all that stuff like because i'm the
owner of the car
you got this take a picture of it you're
right
yeah if your girl goes like he's out of
town i'll pay it right now okay because
he was being a dick last night and and i
bet he's
not because your girl's pretty he's not
gonna be a dick to your pretty girl nah
she's like yo what do you need to
do he was so civil and all that she was
like okay cool let's go
girl flirts with a little bit yeah okay
okay do one of these numbers
yep play with that old junkyard ding
dong right what numbers
wait hold on play with that old junkyard
dude brainstorming
know oh what's his what's his uh oh oh
that's the one right there yeah
um i like i i was a good imitation yeah
yeah it might work
yeah it migrated
my [ __ ] once is
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
seriously that's the extra 1500 what
i'm gonna get it back yeah that's a
great idea i'm a caller yeah call your
girl
have to figure out why so you have to
deal with it yeah that'd be so nice
well at least we figured it out it took
us 15 minutes 20 minutes something like
that yes
we narrowed it down to stressful i mean
we went through all this crap for that
we went through like being [ __ ] boys
cat having to rub a dude
rub a dude out you you getting that big
dick out on cat's
cat's only fans you have your your brain
just go so extreme yeah
the fact that the most logical thing was
call your girls
we eventually got that to that place
though yeah we did we did it
and honestly we saw who was down and who
wasn't chin i'm looking at you
chin was down to house what's happening
dude he was already working on it yeah
yeah that's why he was that's why he was
a little quiet you know he didn't seem
too down for our plan
cat yeah what's up with that you knew
the secret sauce
and i said chappelle can knock him out
and i will pay chappelle
you did say that you did say yes i will
bail him out chappelle you was in it as
well you're right other
he showed up to the casino george
clooney did do time
did we have some rankings i'm not sure
we're doing it this week
all right he was gonna
so thank you for reminding me so it's
going to be thick boy ride
gmail.com so thick with three c's that's
where you would submit your your rank
your pictures your videos whatever
presease
boy ride yeah gmail submit your
uh i think we're calling a rate my state
that's where you can submit yourself
your girlfriend by state whoever you
want for us to see if they're what what
they are on the la scale of one to ten
but also if you send in your city we'll
give you your city scale
you know oh yeah we'll give the city
skills now i was told i'm a naples
eight what's that and naples that's the
streets
what's your damn naples eight yeah
aren't there only old people in naples
i don't know i've never i have no idea
what it's like yeah i have no idea
we don't know anything about and i also
heard from chrissy d and
theo vaughn who have done shows there
that the owner of the club captain brian
forced you to call him captain brian and
chrissy
goes he's never had me back because he
picked me up from the airport and he's
like captain brian's like oh what's up
brian he's like no no it's captain brian
and chrissy was like
well i'm a grown man so i'm not gonna
call you captain he's like well the
name's captain he's like well i'm not
quite a captain he goes he never had me
back
damn damn still calm that's like a bride
all right that's like a pimp named
slickback captain ryan
my thing and i guess he's in a whole get
up like a whole [ __ ]
you know like a captain sailor well
that's kevin no he's like
outfit like captain morgan oh but i said
does he own a boat and chris is like i
don't think so dude
if we if we find jet skis we jet skiing
oh yeah yeah
well you can go a little faster this
time i'll go a little faster yeah i
think
you know it can't tip over it can but
unless you
just i didn't realize it was really hard
to tip those things super tough that was
the thing that's why i was so scared
because you saw me doing donuts dog
boring videos you're not trying to get
the angle right
it's just like he's just doing doughnuts
just behind them
i want to do a jet ski man you've been
on jet skis before i've been on a dirt
bike
yeah that's the same if you're like me
man
and you were forced to take a second
language in high school or college your
boy took french
i can't speak french right so for most
of us learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point of our careers academically all
right
now thanks to babel the number one
selling language learning app
there's a fun and easy way to learn a
new language
listen i'm the only person my house
didn't speak spanish so i have babble
i'm trying to pick up
my kid talk [ __ ] about me whether you're
traveling abroad connecting a deeper way
with your family like your boy
or you just have some free time you want
to pick up a second language babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons that
you actually use in the real world
all right i'm trying to learn spanish
for god's sakes and it's tough
at my age 38 picking up second language
okay thanks babel
babble's 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a
new language on the go all right you can
do it
while you're on the airplane while
you're driving in your car
while you're working out download it man
get it going babble designs their
courses with practical real world
conversations in mind
they're tossing out all that stuff that
you learned in school we're talking
about real stuff that you're gonna use
with this new language with battle you
can choose from 14 different languages
including spanish
french italian and german heard germans
the toughest sites chinese
either way figure it out babel speech
recognition technology helps you to
improve your
pronunciation and accent i could use in
english so if they have english i'll
probably try that out
start your new language learn journey
today with babel right now when you
purchase a three month babel
subscription
you get an additional three months free
that's six months for just the price of
three just go to babel.com use the pro
code fighter
that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot com code fighter
for an extra three months free
babble language for life this episode of
fighter on the kids is brought to you by
unleashed with dingo and danny a new
podcast fueled by monster energy unleash
gets up close and personal with the best
alternative action in motorsports get
ready for untold stories career defining
moments and inside secrets from the
world's best athletes and trailblazers
don't miss out
on all the action new episodes drop
every two weeks on mondays
listen wherever you get your podcast or
watch on monster energy's youtube
unleash with danny and the dingo fueled
by monster energy
you've been on jet skis before i've been
on a dirt bike
yeah that's the same yeah with the
collection
all right coming for you sheila clutch
yeah yeah cause when you clutch you
gotta but you don't have that on now
it's only it's only
go yeah and that's it there's forward
and backwards yeah
the way the way you break is by going in
reverse
so yeah reversing reverse and break are
the same thing what
yeah oh reverse so there's no clutch
there's no gears yeah there's no gears
and if you're not going forward if
you're not pressing yeah
or what do you call it yeah throttle
twist sorry if you're not hitting the
throttle
when you turn if you just turn it's not
going to turn no yeah it has to happen
you have to have throttle when you turn
yeah okay yeah
you get mixed up sometimes you have
probably okay chin with the jet ski
hopefully i want to get better jet skis
i feel like those were older they were
older
like dope on those right there's all
these dimes in the water i was like
you're now shooting a musical oh what's
that oh that's what uh announce the
title fight yawn versus glover
that's actually really good john just
beat uh he deserves it
yeah wait so what's light heavyweight
it's underneath heavy weight 205 206
206 and under oh we got it so the next
weight class is 185 middleweight 185.
got it man get that dick why do you use
that you may hear why you use that as
the thumbnail
what is it that freaking this jackass
get out of that [ __ ] thumbnail where
there
what is it
angles angles he
[Applause]
look at me normal look at me straight
raise your lips no his teeth are fine
no he doesn't have that are you sure no
that one that's
that's the angle oh yeah you're right
holy [ __ ] it's the angle it's just the
angle it's just the angle
that's all your teeth are [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you
are yours in that but
i mean yours has the flavor with the
ghetto yeah
but that's but this is good everything
else is good
good huh yeah pretty straight i'll give
you that nice gums too
you have nice guys he said this was rape
and now
hold on if we're gonna go rape my teeth
and break my tooth
just in a one no don't do it wait did
joseph have my teeth
don't know he doesn't have bad teeth
y'all was talking about tupac what y'all
saying about two pack j yeah all i'm
saying and i
i hate to do it on the show he has
plaque on
the bottoms he has bad bad plaque
now i noticed that when i talked to him
but again that's because he didn't
he he don't get clean he'll get teeth
cleaning now he's doing it he did it
recently
he did it recently so if you see it he
got great teeth so it's not a one i'm
quiet i'd have to see him y'all was
talking about that behind his back yo he
brought it up i was like oh i think he
does
he was one going in about it not really
going in i just said here you go
i said do you notice just as like plaque
on his teeth i said
i want to say something like just take
her
he started going to dental school
he started reading the books he's like
man let me learn how to do this help my
boy
hey you was gonna do it
i was like hey you know what she's doing
austin get our teeth cleaned
you know we do on friday we're gonna go
to the dentist everybody hey justin it's
just you and me though
and by just you and me it's you're just
gonna go at noon
everybody else you always just stay
asleep everyone you guys stay in be
adjusting guys
you can't give me no
our boys sold out this show in denver
though yeah yeah jay wett
yeah it was outdoor yeah yeah jay went
yeah he came on the cutting edge
like i didn't tell you so how are you
gonna come to denver not tell me i was
like bro that
i mean i'm born and raised there dog
yeah why don't you tell me so i can help
you sell tickets
hey you did you know cause you met you
helped him uh get his bonus
yeah so when you post on the fighter in
the kids and uh and my his personal and
i created his flyers
he was like well i said there's two
shows at 7 45 and 9 45 he's like
no it's one show but it ends and i'm
like this makes no sense yeah
he gotta stop it's all the clubs you the
club's pro on themselves not you
yeah look at that look how small he is
on the flyer yeah and then they're
looking like he's just
like look at the flyer i made so the
flyer yeah where's the fire
how's he knocking about the fire you may
go up chin in denver in different
the little bubble or whatever that's
circular yeah generate this one
why the hell am i in his little bubble
thing oh cause y'all went to austin
look at that how filthy is that yeah
one shot i said justin this looks like
and he got the ovo jacket on yeah i know
look at him he was right there in front
of hollywood
dude is that not saturday night live
justin elliott
that's hard the ovo
they're all like
you helped him meet his bonus man he
said he showed up he said uh
talked about a guy who kept like i don't
know if jay mentioned it no oh
i haven't talked to jay about it okay so
the guy kept heckling like a guido guy
kept heckling you know the whole show
before justin got on he was like he was
like jay
if i fire on him you're gonna help me
right oh yeah and then jay was like yeah
yeah because the guy was just so jay
will help jake james said yeah big juicy
bro he'll go up on stage and the hoes be
like man what's up y'all
and go back down like that kind of wow
and then like it was like who was he
on the stage yeah justin was like yo
security what are you doing he was like
[ __ ] i'm secure
wow he was like bro it is always weird
when security doesn't do
anything well i hate it and this is the
old for the longest security black dog
we don't need to do [ __ ] because
anyone does anything you got this i'm
like i don't though dude
yeah i don't want to fight it exactly
like that's why they pay you guys i
don't want to fight anybody
so they do say that to you every time
it's annoying yeah
um so then he's good he was good though
do you know
something nah so the guy left before
justin got oh that's good and he was
like oh this is the white hooded show i
ever been to
that's good yeah jay said it was great
and then who justin he said a guy from
the coming story yep there has been
jerry spinning yeah you know
i have to see him you're hilarious i'm
i'm sure if i see him right now i'm sure
he's sorry dearest i'm awful with names
so
it's okay personally is it on his thing
or no that's him actually
let me just see a picture there's been
that's darius bennett bro oh yeah he's
great
he's from uh detroit detroit talking
smooth catching
he's [ __ ] smooth cat man yeah one of
the funniest dudes out there yeah he's
funny
look look he got different shoes on oh
like which is a tim and a con
he was like cash app so i can buy the
other shoe oh yeah
bro he's so [ __ ] so funny yeah
i gave him a guest spot in austin he
just [ __ ] ripped it he's a beast
he's a beast justin tell him before he
was like just he was like listen
darius you i'm i'm uh michael jackson
you tito
okay he says you know justin you know
justin told uh darius that yeah because
he was like oh
there you start cooking he's like bro
you only doing 10 minutes oh yeah
bro but like you kind of gotta let him
know because he's a savage because he's
just
sad in the room he was like man so soon
as he got off the stage because there is
cooked
for like 20 minutes he was like my bad
dog yeah
he's he's a tough follower yeah he's a
tough follower
yeah he does he he's a beast yeah i
recently just did a show with him
he's a good guy oh yeah we did i did
does he open for anybody
uh no not right now he's on the climb
yeah he's on the climb now he's doing
he's doing his thing man he add him to
the squad
yeah he's i'm telling you man yeah a lot
of them dj
detroit cats man
taylor's one of those 10 talented guys
out yeah
out of amy just so natural yeah
he's so funny doug yeah and so he's so
funny even in person he's just even
conversations
so funny one time he was real drunk
and i just had uh signed with an agent
or just got dumped back from jfl
and uh he was drunk and we were at the
comedy store he goes
you know you gotta suck dick to make it
he came to my show not this last time
but the time before probably two years
ago when i was in cleveland
he came to the show was me and derek he
came in the back he said yo got drinks
and i was like okay
you know the waitress i'm like hey can
we get him drinks dog she was working
he's a real cool cat bro real cool all
on detroit cats are cool man yeah
they're monsters oh yeah
well let's do some current events
hopefully we have rate my state next
week
you want to do it on wednesdays as you
said or it doesn't matter whatever
monday or wednesdays depend when the
graphic guy gets done
all right first one okay
so the other day a stripper from
sapphire
uh strip club in vegas actually
put out an instagram story with a photo
of money but instead of
the president it's usher's face and she
said that usher went to sapphire strip
club
and he threw out these fake dollar bills
with his face on it
and she ended up uh saying that he's
fake and this is why strippers don't
like working with celebrities because
they're actually really cheap
and a bunch of people put them on blast
there was a thread on i believe twitter
of people saying that like usher in one
way or another has like scammed people
like he'd go on into stores try and
close and then leave with them without
paying
but sure but after like it started going
viral
the manager of sapphire came out and
said
he actually paid the girls properly he
paid the
management the staff all the girls but
one person that he
was working with throughout these uh
fake dollar bills promotion for his
residency in vegas
oh so it's like a joke but it that was
amongst
other actual dollar bills that he was
throwing oh so that's some
you know that's just a great stripper
that's a funny ass picture before about
like a day or two everyone thought that
usher was walking around with fake
dollar bills with his face on it
throwing it at strippers
did that say anything him and his team
uh i didn't say anything the manager of
sapphire
because it's so ridiculous yeah then i
can engage in that nobody
but also that stripper i bet the mayor's
like what the [ __ ] he's never gonna come
back here now like he paid all like all
your friends got paid i'm sure he got
paid
but you want to get some extra cloud off
this he's not gonna come he's going to
[ __ ] experiment right now now
you [ __ ] us this is a strip club in
atlanta no no
no no no vacations
yeah got all the baddies you fly all the
way satisfied is pretty good
it is what about hustlers the one on top
of uh i'm writing on the hustlers man
sas fires and spearmint you're in spring
you go to strip
yeah i heard him didn't you go to the
big girl one in long beach don't worry
about that
you talked about it it was a little
worried about when we referenced this
we're talking about back in the day
exactly yeah when you reverse dream club
yeah yeah okay
it's called bounce by the way if you
want to
slide up and bounce okay
so what's crazy about uh spearmint
rhinos back in the day
because you know las vegas has a lot of
mma fighters
back in the day the security experiment
rhino was roy
nelson and frank mayer oh [ __ ] that was
the ufc
yeah i mean frank mayer one of the
greats roy nelson one of the greats that
and they were young in the game
yeah who they were but that i frank was
in the ufc when he was working at sprint
rental he's the head of security roy was
the other
bouncer so they would be at the front so
you got problems
those those those are the boys tossing
out [ __ ]
that's crazy but dope and roy actually
met his wife she was a bartender there
yeah they don't play about those
strippers in
the security and strip club [ __ ] no they
and they shut it bro yeah some scumbags
i watch pink valley and
they they don't what's that uh show
about the strip club
oh it's like a scripted series yeah what
else you got
so there is currently a ketchup shortage
that the u.s
cannot keep up with because the heinz
factory has been shut down for a while
because it covered yeah because of covid
and what ended up happening was
uh now that people are buying a lot of
takeout a lot of food delivery ketchup
is the most popular condiment that
people will ask
tigers gonna be pissed uh restaurants
had to
try to find other brands other than
heinz heinz kind of like loki has
monopoly on ketchup
so when they went uh and shut down all
these other businesses
started to have their ketchup supplies
be bought up and now there's a
nationwide shortage
i don't really [ __ ] with heinz although
heinz did release a sugar-free
like they have a non-additive sugar one
but we get tiger that [ __ ] one from
whole foods where there's not sugar in
it oh yeah
there's so much sugar in uh ketchup a
lot of sugar tons of sugar
i didn't know people were still [ __ ]
with ketchup like oh okay
fries ketchup and fruit what's your
favorite condiment none if you don't use
ketchup for stuff
[ __ ] ranch ranch that's fair that's
just kind of
a lot of calories i like the aiolis and
stuff that's basically just mayonnaise
like the chipotles and [ __ ] like that i
like that
yeah i probably like that like more than
the than the ranch and stuff but
yeah i mean ketchup i didn't have
anything ketchup is that ketchup with
fries or like a nice cheeseburger with
ketchup
only oh man for man a flame broiled
burger king
whopper with cheese and ketchup only i
never ketchup burger king like that
i like just fries every day i like the
fries oh burger king fries yeah i like
bread pretty
fries but wait anything else there
actually i like those little
chicken sticks they have oh they're
chicken fries chicken fries the chicken
tenders are fire too with their barbecue
sauce
and they're chicken sandwiches i'm a
burger king guy over mcdonald's oh
really seriously
damn there's not too many people that i
don't think about this dude
heaven on earth if my last meal would be
a whopper ketchup
that's your last meal oh yeah what damn
it's so much that's what i grew up
on as a kid the i was part of memories
yes
nobody take me after uh school every day
oh okay
all right okay so chet hanks released
his white boy summer anthem the other
day
here is the full music video i can't
wait summer
kind of goes hard
in that video i know y'all saw that we
gotta get him on the [ __ ] dude
i i reached out to uh i reached out to
his manager on imdb
and i went to his instagram yesterday
because i was just gonna dm
him from the fighter and the kid
instagram but i saw that he had another
manager listed so i
reached out to him have gianni dim
through my account all right
there you are let me see you make it
twerk yeah let me make it twerk
man that song is fine that's just fire
what do you think mal i'm just so
curious when you want to be on the remix
i'm just so curious when he shows his
dad what tom hanks thinks of it
i know yeah what does his dad think no
no what if he was just vibing to it like
yeah
he's like god this is cool being like
the uh the boston host thing from oh my
god
oh yeah yeah step brothers dude that
[ __ ] movie
still hits oh yeah so good class love
that dude why are you sweating i just
got finished watching cops yeah
you touched my drums
[Laughter]
chat put out the banger man yeah yeah
i guess this girl suing him for a
million dollars though i saw that yeah
she photoshopped herself in the in front
of the courtroom or something like that
the front of the courthouse
she did yeah wait why she's she a baddie
um right that's the same girl that
remember he did a video
yeah she's not like yeah wait what uh
why is she suing him
because i think it's because of like
verbal and physical abuse
[Music]
you could sue someone for that i guess i
didn't know you verbal well physical
abuse you can
not verbal yeah wait she said verbal
just verbal abuse she's saying verbal
and physical
oh gotta get all around here sorry he's
gonna settle out of court i bet
yeah and you got i thought this thing
was fake until
yeah you got real yeah it got real it
got real it was a while ago
not not recently yeah last year last
year yeah yeah i think now that he's
popping off now
everything's kind of complicated and he
has merch coming out
good for him yeah okay this is a
feel-good one i guess uh a chimp is
reunited with two people who
uh took care of him as a baby when he
was abandoned by his mother gosh i love
these videos
how cool is that
[Music]
oh that's cool
[Music]
you better be careful to rip that face
off girl
i'm so happy
[Music]
oh he's cute ah [ __ ] man
seven broken ribs
now he's crushing it miami
[Laughter]
swinging around and chilling on south
beach zoo culture
damn that's cool
[Music]
well that's sweet sweet that's cool
i want a monkey bruh
it's illegal to own a monkey right yeah
i think it's illegal now yeah i think i
never heard that lady that had one no
this guy ripped her face off
no though like this guy just bought a uh
guy that's uh
uh jonathan white i am jonathan white on
instagram he always posts uh
michael jackson he's here in the states
or no he's in miami no uh white with r-i
uh g-h-t oh like right yeah oh right
yeah
uh michael jackson had to get rid of his
monkey w same as justin bieber i think
he bought it somewhere and then he's
gonna come back
because they say after a while like baby
monkeys they get uh
he's still owning he literally they get
aggressive ah bro he got a baby
i'm telling you oh he's got a baby one
but yeah but that's not a chip
no but you i don't think you'd have
those i wonder if it's like a special
license that you can
have if you work with animals there's
someone like on friends
those type of monkeys right yeah yeah
like also marshall kid though you know
are they marshmallows
mercedes are probably kangaroos right oh
yeah he got he got them they
you got all they there's another one now
it's a different one yeah go take it out
go to his instagram
story i am dior the monkey got his own
instagram story no so clicking this uh
video
clicking the video use this one this one
yeah and type and click on imdr in his
caption up there yeah that's his own you
get
all his videos who's this guy jonathan
right he uh
looks like the stories well there's no
stories right now there's no stories
he's just all posts of his monkey that's
just
just the monkey huh yeah and look you
feed him and he he bought like three of
them at the end
what does jonathan wright do
i didn't see that video but uh i just
said i wanted a monkey and i think y'all
said i can't have one but he owns like
three of them huh
yeah it's dicey in la i don't know are
there a bunch of people in texas who own
tigers
yeah i think even that's illegal now
and the leash yeah
but he's in miami right he's in miami
but he's off to a permit
hey hey let's just worry about your
sentra
all right thank you for keeping me on
track what else you got uh do you guys
watch the bachelor
anyone here hell yeah well i know what
you're going to go to i called it from
the very first day me and my girl we
only liked the early episodes of the
bachelor mm-hmm
there you go god he gives off a gay vibe
my girl grows i bet you he's gay with no
but he's on the bachelor
i was like he gives off a super gay vibe
now there's anything
no it's good that he's coming out
finally yeah i mean you wasted every one
of those poor girls time
for that but that's not what he was he
was the one picking girl he was the best
sir that means yeah okay hey he just
came out this morning he's the flavor
flavor of the show
thank you i mean let me see it you get a
rose i knew he was gay from the jump
though
you want people to know i'm gay
and i came to terms with that earlier
this year and have been processing it
that's basically oh i called it
yeah the only thing i find weird about
this is why you like go on a press tour
to tell people that's what i'm sitting
now that's the only like thing i'm kind
of like
is he promoting something you know you
want to create buzz did he marry someone
off of the show no no
she actually put a restraining order on
him
and took it back i think and he also
dated a really popular olympian
ali raisman mm-hmm oh the um gymnastics
yeah right yeah super diamond later for
a
while
i don't want to disrespect anyone
because i don't know his agenda but
sometimes i think he's a hidden agenda
that go on a press tour
and be like yo yeah i'd see i i i do see
her he's that boy's gay yeah yeah
if you watch that with the show he's gay
i just think
you felt it the whole time you did these
just you know this is
just sugar in your tank there's sugar in
your tank dead
like it's you know it's it is what it is
that's the way life works man
daddy can't fight it no no you can't
take that
[ __ ] yeah
yeah but he's like i i do think he's
actually gay but it's like you know
these women
like on these pr tours like with terry
crews right when he said he was sexually
harassed
by that agent how long ago was his
episode
or his season two years ago maybe a year
ago
fairly recently do they stay pretty
relevant after i feel like now
they do yeah definitely the pandemic i
feel like all those type of reality
shows just kind of blew up and now these
are like household names like love
island
yes you feel like he could have just
done it on the ground yeah like elliott
paige
the girl she she used to be known as
2019 ellen page she did on her
instagrams and then
she then she did an article like a
magazine show she wanted a little bit of
press store too though
but after she she announced the online
person but but i bet you he
uh told his family and friends and then
did this
yeah it is weird i mean i i mean i guess
you're going good more in america to do
it
good for him regardless
did you watch it no i would have never
known i mean
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i've seen it somewhat but
but you know you only knew because you
was like man i called it
oh yeah see i never watched the show i
don't know i don't know
much you never watch the bachelor or
good morning america uh you both both
yeah
i'm so in love i know from the midnight
i meant i'm like oh my god
they all be saying that huh all of them
or the producers are getting them to say
you're flying to paris for a date for
the afternoon like once the show's over
you're going back to
[ __ ] kentucky in his two-bedroom
apartment
and all this [ __ ] stops we'll see if you
love them oh it's rare they ever work
out yeah
it's not real oh i understand it's just
entertainment
yeah i mean a few have stayed together
and had kids and stuff but in general it
never works out
it's a hot mess my favorite is when they
had the black girl on
and they had uh black contestants on
there you know
they're playing basketball all right
that's racist whatever
and the one guy's playing he's like
we're doing well in the game
and his girl shows up she's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
no he had a straight up full-blown
girlfriend bro he's on the back you have
a video
i think that happened recently on the
american love island like the guy
who won in one of the previous seasons
his girlfriend
girlfriend came out that's the new one
wait on love island uh the us one uh
i don't know like it's gonna come out
dude
he's getting so many death threats
because of that uh
dude uh no the guy who is
on love island usa he won he had a
secret girl this is it right here
look at this girl look at this look at
him talking to the girl
oh who's this who's this
real player real player what's this
real player on the bachelorette and
while everyone was excited about
surprise guest kareem abdul-jabbar
damario wasn't so excited about the
other surprises
his alleged girlfriend lexi you thought
you could walk on with an engagement
ring in your pocket and tell this girl
you were ready to wife her when you were
in my bed
weeks before you were texting me you
think that you're out of this i have a
full-on paper training
demario tried to explain that he wasn't
double dribbling
and that he had broken up with lexi
before coming on the ship
i went over to our house i explained to
her that look you and i are just going
father's
she even looks kind of psycho thank just
her looks thank you i believe
he was in my house unfortunately i
believe her
i believe her he's
who is this hilarious i can't believe
they let her on of course they'll let
her of course yeah
i feel like a producer found out like
you want to come on the show yeah you
want to come on the chef you want to
sneak up on him but hey kudos to him to
keep staying in character though
but he already [ __ ] up you got his
thing who is he who is this and then he
says oh we broke up like you can't
double
you can't go back on that you gotta just
pretend like you don't know her the
entire thing is
he was just disqualified in week two
because they found him
disqualified out of basketball got a
basketball game
he just met kareem abdul-jabbar
remember he had some controversy with
this girl she said that
she was actually like hitting on him and
kissing him and later on she said that
he took advantage of her or something
like that
and then they saw the footage and she
was just so drunk she forgot happened i
feel like nick told me something about
that wait who's that girl
she's also on the bachelorette season
something i don't know
calm down now she knows she looks like
this yeah yeah yeah
you're looking you're liking that he put
them
i did a show with her she tried to stand
up hey that's why
i was like oh that girl looked familiar
because i did a show with him yeah
that's why
there you go that's how i remember her
name korean
i think she was dating someone at the
time too or something like that and she
was embarrassed so she was like oh my
god
yeah okay then but they're recording
everything yeah so
yeah they try to get my mess yeah i know
they did she tried too
she tried she don't get the blame that's
right and his girlfriend
she had no business being there brother
look for love now
they paid me a thousand dollars a week
and you [ __ ] up he's just picking the
wrong one
that's it yeah you get paid to be on
that show the
uh yeah yeah so wait what if there's
another a spin-off bachelor thing oh so
it's bachelor bachelorette
yeah so if you know what how did they
come together
oh i think she was on bachelor in
paradise and so they all the most famous
ones go on uh yeah
island and they go on an island and it's
like their shitty version of love island
oh okay it's not as good oh okay
um american idol news i'm sure you know
this already my favorite thing
right yeah wyatt pike quits that there's
a guy that brendan was like
the guitarist guitar played favorite he
just quit here's what i think happened
like online they think it's because of
covid it's not they would have said if
it was
yeah that's easy i think you know
because his last performance he crushed
it and luke bryant was like you're going
to make
music for i remember that part he's like
cool story i
because if you go to the top 10 you sign
a contract with
uh abc or american idol so you're in
that contract
i think he knew he's gonna make the top
ten i think someone came to know i was
like dude get out of that it's gonna
[ __ ] contract we'll give you a full
contract he's like good idea
i quit because he probably listened to
the episode where we talked about those
comments
i see what you did there shout out to
you oh you say that boy
life yep yep but yeah luke bryan did say
like even if you don't make it you're
gonna you're gonna
play this for the rest of your life yeah
you're gonna be doing this for the rest
of your life i think he got a
contract offered from another place and
that's what he's going to do because
some yeah someone probably reached out i
was like yo contract's shitty
listen to the fighter and the kids saw
you from finding kids brendan was
talking about it he broke it down for
him
chappelle he got the george clooney you
know [ __ ]
spitballing you know running it he said
you got something here so go ahead
that's what i think happened good for
him yeah
this is really nothing it's not really
an event but it's just vin diesel
posted
yeah i'm in the middle of dawn press
for the trailer release of fast nine
that comes out
on april 14th
and i'm so excited for you to see it
different world doing press and and
their virtual capacity but
uh it's always great to see my fast
family all of which i'm
so so proud of i can use a little more
energy or whatever universal which i'm
so proud of
um happy creative sunday
so we're in the middle of the day that's
it
can we watch that i didn't they already
have the trailer this comes out today
yeah
they're slowly getting more and more
ridiculous yeah yeah they're gonna be
going to the moon now
two hours ago they're going to the moon
let's get it let's get it man
the world has the way of changing
oh i can't wait when the rock come in
i feel like we've seen it all yeah rock
is not i don't need to see it look
hey what did they take bow wow under the
series
even that kid from a home improvement
was like the bully remember the older
brother
i forgot
yeah don't get me wrong that scene was
bad but i mean i just
i think he has troubles right now though
yeah he's in trouble right now who
just kind of exactly yeah oh he looks
different oh
what happened to oh damn yeah he's in
some trouble what do you do
i think he beat his wife or something
like that oh [ __ ] he's from aurora
colorado shout out to royal colorado he
does not represent aurora
yeah probation for domestic violence
yeah i can't have that he's smiling in
the picture smiling
he's smiling he looks so like something
is up here
he's struggling with something yeah he
knows he knows what he's in for yeah
he's [ __ ]
yeah um you want one quick one
sure man this is just one that since
we're on uh
tyrese anyways this is tyrese post you
see this video
no uh watch
so the guy has cancer and the barber cut
his hair
barbara had fresh ass hair too that was
so dope
right simple bro
did you see the video they said that
looked like you if you was uh in the
streets
uh-uh in the barber chair you had like
waves oh yeah oh no yeah he's like
drinks
i don't even know if that was drake that
was a fat ass drake for this i wasn't
drinking
water a funny picture
here it's dope yeah uh we're off to
naples today man
so far we gotta fly in a day early
naples florida this thursday friday
saturday comedy off the hook naples
florida captain brian we'll call you
captain see you soon
next week thursday friday saturday
austin
texas balkan gas company in austin texas
we're adding a late show
thursday night so if you get tickets you
miss out on vip tickets and get them
thursday night show
that's next week thursday friday
saturday austin then houston
may 20th through the 22nd houston improv
and then just announce oklahoma city
oklahoma one of my favorite clubs
bricktown june 10th through the june
12th
all right tickets at f a t k z dot com
chappelle will also be in philly at the
helium comedy club may
6th through the 8th and then raleigh
north carolina at good night's comedy
club
may 13th through the 15th is helium full
capacity
uh no ah they're not full capacity it's
a great club you done that one
i'm excited i've never been to philly
yeah it's great well my favorite should
i
try a cheesesteak yeah should i try it
yeah they're nice a little overrated but
then
oh sorry oh no my boy's a suplex to take
you to where you should go
don't no don't go to the uh yeah don't
go to those places
don't go to work they'll take you a
place up the street from soup i really
got good food in philly the best
i love philly one of my favorite spots
you know i can't get to get too crazy
with the food you can try some though
straight to their spot it's great oh
really they know the good spot okay i'm
excited for philly
and north carolina it is all right
naples we'll see you this week austin
next week love you guys we're out